flight six one seven eight had just
taken off from Tchaikovsky Airport in
Moscow when the emergency happened the
oral airlines early morning flight from
Moscow to Simferopol in Crimea hit a
flock of seagulls birds were sucked into
both engines disabling them as the
pilots of the Airbus a321 lost power and
hide they had no choice but to glide
towards a crash landing
the airliner came down in a cornfield a
kilometer from the runway the pilot gave
instructions to passengers how to
evacuate the 233 passengers and crew
onboard escaped shaken but all alive
we're lucky that we landed in the field
god forbid we had landed somewhere else
the flight attendants immediately opened
emergency exits and inflated the other
patients light and everyone started
helping each other many were running
away barefoot but everyone is alive tens
of passengers needed hospital treatment
some are badly bruised when 21 year old
suffered a head injury although its fuel
tanks were full there was no fire during
the landing and the pilots didn't deploy
the landing gear to ensure a softer
landing to minimize the impact a V Asian
experts say the crash has similarities
with the so called Miracle on the Hudson
in New York ten years ago the airplane
got very bad event but nobody got hurt
and I hope the future events will be
like that yes it's just a matter of
chance there are lots of birds in the
sky if a big flock of big birds it's
both engines then you are committed to a
forced landing Thursday's crash in
Russia follows another one in May when
41 people died in an unborn fire at an
out of moscow airport in june two people
died when an airliner burst into flames
when it overshot a runway in Siberia
another crash is raising concerns about
the safety record of Russian Airlines
but these pilots and
being hailed as heroes to saving the
lives of everybody on board
a criminal investigation now has to
provide answers to what exactly has
happened and if a dump sided attract
scavenging Birds near this new airport
has something to do with it stepheson al
jazeera Moscow